في صباح يوم الثال عش من اكتوبر الجاري
طالب المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي سكان مدينه غزه باخلاقها
والتوجه الى الجنوب زاعما ان قواته ستتوقف
عن قصف المسار المحدد حتى الثامنه من مساء
نفس اليوم ونشر خريطه تحدد المسار الامن
والقت طائرات الاحتلال الاف المنشورات
التي تحمل نفس الرساله وكانما استدرج الى
فخ يلقون فيه
حتفهم استجاب العشرات لاوامر التهجير لكن
قوات الاحتلال قصفت مركباتهم في الممر
الامن
المزعوم بتحليل المقطع الفيديو امكن تحديد
موقعه بدقه عبر مطابقه المعالم الظاهره في
الفيديو وتحديدها على الخ خريطه تبين ان
القصف وقع على بعد 6 كيلومترات فقط من
مدينه غزه في المسار المحدد من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي عند شارع صلاح الدين بمنطقه حي
الزيتون وبملاحظة
الاعلامي الفلسطيني قدر عدد الضحايا بسين
شهيده اغلبهم من النساء والاطفال واكثر من
200 مصاب ذنبهم الوحيد انهم اعتقدوا انه
يمكن الوثوق في عهود جيش
الاحتلال